hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here with some
glorious hunter hunter quite
specifically 10 fun facts about jing
freaks that you did not know and if you
did then i don't care because they're
still gonna be fun and i've chosen jing
for this video because he's quite the
mysterious dude bruh full of lots of
irony i mean i for one find it quite
interesting that he decided to name his
son after his parenting style both of
which are of course gone but jing really
does form a fascinating core of hunter
hunter without him gone doesn't go on a
journey and without gone going on a
journey we don't have a series so you
could say that everything we've
experienced was very much designed to
build up this mystery man who has
actually become something of a primary
protagonist during our dark continent
storyline so let's discover some fun
facts about jing and it is all going to
commence with a quick round of hunter
trivia a very simple minigame where i
ask you a multiple choice question and
you being you provide an answer to said
question however should you answer
incorrectly then your punishment will be
to subscribe to the new world review
which will also result in consistent
injections of hunt-based content
administered directly into your youtube
feed and if you do answer correctly then
you will move on to the next phase of
our hunter exam so speaking of here is
our question how old was jing when he
passed the hunter exam was he a 10 b11
or c12 all ages that are quite frankly
far too young for this sort of
shenanigan but hey it's jing so make
your choice now and we shall reveal the
answer in three two one and bam jing was
11 years old when he took the hunter
exam or more accurately according to
mito it was done before jing turned 12
which in some circles would be
considered 11. so if you guessed
incorrectly then you know the thing to
do and please do say hi in the comments
below if you are new to our association
welcome but this leads quite nicely into
jing fact number one because whilst he
may have been 11 that wasn't even the
most impressive aspect of jing's
particular hunter exam because he is
actually notable as the only passing
candidate of his year that being the
267th hunter exam and just a bonus fun
fact while we're here we do actually
know of one of the other participants of
this exam which was of course ton per
the rookie crusher and by this time ton
perhaps actually participated in more
than 10 previous hunter exams it's
interesting to think about though
because he clearly failed to crush jing
just as he would fail to crush gone
almost exactly 20 years later also gone
was 11 years old when he took the hunter
exam maybe and like it's kind of
difficult to confirm actually because
gone's age is the subject of a lot of
inconsistencies within the wonderful
hunthunt timeline but in theory his
journey was meant to mirror jing so
togashi's intention was for gone to b11
still what's more impressive is that it
looks like jing was able to solo the
hunter exam in a way that gone really
would not have been able to which leads
us quite nicely into fun fact number two
because as is predictable with such a
solid career start jing has actually
achieved the highest possible rank that
a hunter can within the association sort
of all right let me explain the hunter
association distinguishes its high
performers via a three-star ranking
system three obviously being the highest
because that would be the mostest and to
put that into some perspective a veteran
hunter like moral has been awarded one
star whilst biski is currently a
two-star hunter whereas jing is one of
the rare hunters who has qualified to
receive his triple star license however
he is not officially a triple star
hunter because and while there's no was
really no other way to put this he can't
be bothered to go and get it in order to
receive this upgrade a hunter needs to
submit an application and now this this
is very problematic because jing and
administration well they don't really
mix so the only thing stopping him from
being recognized as one of the highest
ranking hunters in the entire
association is sheer laziness and that
laziness very much spawns from fun fact
number third which is all about jing
zodiac sign as the boar not his actual
astrology sign because funnily enough it
doesn't match but jing was deemed a
hunter competent or i suppose
interesting enough to become one of
isaac nataro's trusted zodiacs being
assigned to the role of boar a boar
basically being a glorified piggy and
this reflects jin quite well because in
chinese astrology the boar is notorious
for never being on time in fact the only
reason why it was designated as the 12th
sign is because our pigeon allegedly
overslept and was the last to meet with
the jade emperor and you can see this
quite clearly with jing specifically in
his first modern appearance because he
is the last of the zodiacs to reach the
hunter association following the death
of chairman netera although
interestingly enough because the hunter
hunt world does somehow follow our date
system we can determine the birth year
of jing which is 1967 and that would
make him a sheep not a pig so in
conclusion all hail jing the magical
mighty sheep pig none of that really
matters though because our unfortunate
fourth fact is that jing is incredibly
unpopular within the world of hunter
hunter and especially within the hunter
association itself i mean yeah there are
a few characters like satots who hold
jing in very high regard but they are
quite few and far between and we can see
this effect at play during the german
election where jing was of course
running for the top job however the most
votes he received at any given time
during this entire process was a mere
eight and assumedly one of those votes
was himself so there were only seven
other hunters in the entire association
that deemed jing trustworthy enough for
that chairman role meanwhile the large
majority of hunters despised him so much
that they even broke into a spontaneous
round of applause when leorio struck
jing with his remote bunch and look even
jinx's close collaborators amongst the
zodiacs held him at the very least in a
very strong distaste all except for the
most unlikely person that is which forms
a big part of jing fact number five
being that he is the only human being
possibly even the only being in the
world who is hated by pariston hill now
i know that might seem like a bit of a
bit of a petty fact at first but this is
actually pretty massive barristan is an
intriguing guy because he has never
actually hated anybody in his life until
he met jing which is both astonishing
and terrifying astonishing that paris
and can go through life with such
neutral dare i even say positive
feelings for all those around him and
terrifying because he does absolutely
sickeningly evil things to those people
regardless these are the people that he
likes or at least doesn't hate and right
now one of our big cliffhangers in the
manga is paris and coming to realize
that he legitimately hates jing because
jing possesses a level of genius to
rival paristan which is annoying very
very annoying but also exciting very
very exciting because paristan is quite
eager to discover exactly what he would
do to someone who he legitimately hates
so jing has nurtured himself quite a
powerful and scary enemy in periston and
not only that but an enemy who is
actually capable of out thinking him
because paristan did get the better of
jing during the chairman election not
that jing should necessarily have too
much to worry about because of fact
number of the one that we're up to what
is it six yeah sounds good in any case
this fact thing is that jing is quite
possibly the most powerful nen user in
the entirety of hunter hunter because if
his status as an informal triple star
hunter as well as the zodiac didn't sway
you well then how about the idea that
isaac netro once told bisky that jing
freaks is one of the top five men users
in the entire world and i do find that
pretty convincing coming from a man like
netero personally but we don't
necessarily need to take netero's word
for it because i would say that from the
minimal amount that jing has
demonstrated in the series he is quite
clearly superior to probably anyone else
we've ever encountered that includes the
ants the ants mostly look tough because
they have disgusting quantities of aura
but as actual and end users they're all
very rough and unrefined including the
king but for an example of refinement
jing did show off a bit in the manga
displaying his capacity to immediately
replicate lyorio's nen abilities but not
just replicate them improve them after
seeing them only once jing understood
the exact aura breakdown of how they
were crafted so he basically just stole
the idea and casually created two new
and too superior and abilities for
himself and that is important to
emphasize because there is a little bit
of a misconception the jinx and ability
is the power to copy other nin abilities
but it is not we still haven't actually
seen any of his original abilities but
jing is just such an outrageous or a
genius that he can replicate the highly
personalized and developed powers of
others as if there was some kind of
basic principle of the art form which
leads us nicely into lucky fact number
seven which i'll be honest is more of an
anti-fact than an actual fact but we
still do not know jing's nen affinity
which is a bit bizarre because there
aren't too many characters in the series
whose affinities have not been revealed
either in the manga or through a data
book and jing just happens to be one of
them also just like the copy myth there
is another strong misconception amongst
the fanbase that jing is a natural
emitter and this spawns entirely from
the fact that leoria's non-abilities
were emissive based but jing replicating
those does not make him an emitter not
necessarily anyway i mean admittedly he
could be but the ease at which he wields
a mission may indicate his position on
the n-ring if not and emitted then
potentially as an enhancer or a
manipulator however i will say that when
you get to the level of being one of the
top five nin users in the world i'm
gonna go ahead and propose that your
position on the nen ring probably
doesn't actually matter a whole lot to
illustrate isaac natural was an enhancer
but his 100 type guanine bodhisattva
primarily seems to make use of
conjuration to summon the statue and
manipulation to move it both of which
are the two worst possible affinities
for an enhancer to be using but he does
it anyway because he's natural and he
doesn't care about your crap now with
all of this said i do have a guess as to
what jing's netfinity might be which is
explored in this here video using facts
and logic potentially cherry-picked
facts and flawed logic but hey we gave
it a go moving along though jing has
made some questionable choices in life
like deciding to say abandon his son and
train him through a series of very
specifically designed death games but
the only action of jing that was ever
censored in hunter hunter is the name he
chose for himself on greed island now
this name just so happened to be
this which let's just say i don't even
feel comfortable saying that much on
youtube but it's basically supposed to
serve as an anagram of jing something
that i'm sure seems fairly innocent to
non-english speakers like say a native
japanese speaker which wow yoshihiro
tagashi just so happens to be what are
the odds as a result though the anagram
and the viz manga translation became
with that said no changes were made to
the official english subtitle anime so
maybe we were just overreacting about
nothing but probably not with that in
mind quite curious that jing would make
such a choice because fact number nine
is that he is a very cultured man
cultured to the point where he knows an
incredible slew of languages just not
english apparently however as a proud
archaeologist jing has also made it his
mission to study ancient languages and
he is allegedly fluent in both ancient
kape and uncle if i'm pronouncing those
correctly and you know what i don't care
because they are fake ancient societies
and i do not respect fake ancient
societies however jing does and in fact
his knowledge is so great that he
engaged in an ancient language contest
with a character named curly who was a
member of beyond netro's expedition team
to the dark continent and as a side note
curly is a professor of the not at all
referential varved university which does
sound nice but jing thoroughly trounced
him which brings us to jing fact number
10 which is that in the 1999 anime he
gets portrayed a little differently
where in both the manga and the 2011
anime jing is very much depicted as a
sort of oversized gone the 1999 anime
makes him significantly more how shall
we say manly and adult-like and it does
vary from shot to shot and it is
particularly vague because this
incarnation only made it to the end of
greed island so we never got to see jing
during any of the election stuff but he
does look significantly more adult like
some sort of man with some sort of
responsibilities as opposed to say gone
with a beard i mean if anything adult
gone actually looks a bit more like a
grown man than jing does in the 2011
anime but hey that only goes on to
emphasize jinx in a child throughout his
whole life jing has never lost that
magical spark for adventure and
knowledge something that has and will
continue to serve him extraordinarily
well as he makes his way to the dark
continent or not maybe his curiosity
will be his undoing and he'll die a
brutal fruitless death but we know it
will be one or the other but to examine
more about stuff here is another video
for you it contains delicious
hunter-based information because there's
always more to learn explore and
experience with this wonderful series so
i look forward to seeing you there